non
annie ce roman bonjour
bonjour merci
alors c'est un peu compliqué parce que
nous sommes deux entités
il ya cette entité le balafon
chromatique et lie à son serviteur
banque gagne est devant vous nous avons
tous deux des choses à dire mais nous
ont fusionné ça sera plus facile alors
il ya un proverbe africain qui dit que
lorsqu'on arrive nouvellement dans un
village alors qu'en général si les gens
marchent sur un pied eh ben il faut
commencer par marcher sur un pied
pourrait être adopté pour être acceptée
ensuite peut-être on pourra proposer un
deuxième pied pour pouvoir être plus
équilibré avancer plus aisément
oui et donc avant de parler de
réinventer les codes et bien il est bien
de parler d' intégrer les codes intégré
les codes tout à l'heure le balafon
chromatique viens de vous dire bonjour
en plusieurs langues africaines
il y avait le baoulé ensuite il ya eu le
bêti ça c'est d'afrique centrale il ya
eu le bassari centrale il y a eu le
joola le bambara
il ya du français
alors il est important de comprendre que
en afrique ce qu'on appelle balafrant
généralement cela dit l'ophone il existe
des centaines de types de l'ilophone des
différents en afrique ce soit en afrique
de l'ouest et en afrique centrale en
afrique australe en afrique de l'est et
une communique pas ensemble parce que
chacun est accordée selon le mode
ethnique auquel il appartient alors on
peut pas les mettre ensemble ou qu'ils
jouent ensemble morceaux de façon
injuste alors l'idée de la création du
balafon chromatique est venu pour
concilier tous et balafon de sorte que
en un seul nous pouvons leur perte
auriez des modes d autres et donc au
lieu d'avoir des containers devant la
fronde différents un seul balafon suffit
il suffit seulement d'y appliquer les
techniques et d'appliquer les
répertoires des autres et nous avons
tous play balafon de fritzl
c'est pour cela que l'invention du
balafon chromatique est une invention
majeure bravo pour la faune chromatique
merci je me permets de m'asseoir ici
parce que j'ai une toute petite histoire
à vous raconter
alors moi je suis né en ville comme la
plupart d'entre vous pas au village
je n'ai pas eu cette chance oui
maintenant c'est pour moi c'est une
chance d'être né au village
alors j'ai grandi dans une univers où on
est bête dès mon arrivée
le père noël m'a bourré de cadeaux et et
de quais et ils ont jeté très très très
très gentil et très obéissants dans tout
de suite le père noël m'apporter des
cadeaux et qu'ils étaient des
instruments de musique
c'était des guitares c'était
des pianos c'était des trompettes et
tout ça et c'est comme ça que j'ai
grandi dans cet univers au point que je
t'ai vraiment ce qu'on appelle un
citadin dans mon enfance s comme ça que
j'ai grandi on pouvait que au cameroun
parce que c'est mon pays d'origine au
pays natal en 1984 par l'hameçon 85
monsieur le directeur de la rti c'était
encore les moments d'expérimentation de
la télévision au cameroun et c'était
vraiment précieux d'avoir comme ça les
premières images tout le temps on
n'avait que trois jours sur 7
mais à l'époque il y avait le vendredi
samedi et le dimanche à partir de 18
heures jusqu'à minuit par là et il s'est
avéré que c'était des moments vraiment
très attendue parce que enfin on pouvait
avoir de la télévision peut avoir des
films on peut avoir plein de choses et
donc le samedi était sacré capture on
attendre de films américains on affine
français dont un film alors là oui ou
bien alors soit 1 samedi soir qu'est ce
que je vois à la télé et je vois un
spectacle de marionnettes africaine
didon mallettes africaines ça me disent
aussi sacré et je lui là mais après une
longue acheter la somalie est ce qu'ils
savent à de compte c'était un spectacle
du chose de wade à viking et pau et
venait de côte d'ivoire il ya présenté
son spectacle et moi je me suis dit mme
etien et n'ont rien compris à la télé
alors qu'elle 80 près que j'ai eu mon
bac et je venais en côte d'ivoire mes
études de médecine
ça n'a pas marché comme je le pensais
avec beaucoup de mythes mac des grèves
de ceci de cela
alors j'ai continué ce que le père noël
m'avait déjà donné dès mon enfance parce
que j'ai continué que ce soit à l'école
primaire que ce soit au collège s'était
déjà des des concerts scolaires et tout
ça et je me suis inscrit en côte
d'ivoire au conservatoire ensuite j'ai
intégré le village qui devenu
aujourd'hui fondation qui évoque avec la
tête le rennais rod fanni king alors ce
que ce que je fuyais à l'époque nous a
attirés au point que je suis devenu
responsable musical du kilim bourque
plus tard et arrangeur maisons du
village qui j'ai découvert enfin le
charme
oui le jambes de l'esthétique africaine
du site panafricaine au point que au
lieu d'avoir honte de mes valeurs plus
d'avoir honte de moi je pouvais être
fier et surtout je pouvait considérer
cela comme mon gagne pain
cinq ans plus tard je revenais au
cameroun avec le kiyi m'bock en tournée
j'étais un professionnel
alors j'arrive au cameroun et bien sûr
là bas tout le monde se pose la question
est ce qu'on peut vivre de son art et
tout ça bon je te parie produit tout de
suite maintenant je peux répondre parce
que en fait la question est mal posée la
question est très mal posé la question
c'est est-ce que vous nourrissez
suffisamment votre art
oui parce que le nombre de temps que
nous mettons pour devenir un ingénieur
le nombre de temps que nous investissons
pour devenir un médecin c'est autant de
temps que nous mettons c'est autant de
d'investissement de sacrifices alors
pour juste quelques semaines de pratique
on se demande si l'art peut nourrir son
homme
non à force d'y aller à force de
perfectionner à pour celui de donner le
meilleur de nous-mêmes et b2 le rend
bien
j'étais donc devenu un professionnel de
la musique
j'ai découvert les îlots phone parce que
j'étais pianiste à l'époque arrangeur
j'étais pas encore tout à fait ce que je
voulais et c'est comme ça que je me suis
rendu compte que tient il y avait
quelque chose à défendre
au lieu de défendre les instruments
occidentaux qui avaient déjà tellement
de défenseurs peut être que nous
pourrions nous aussi défendre notre art
et défendre les nôtres alors je me suis
mis depuis 1997 au balafon
en général les claviers africain de
perfectionnement en perfectionnement le
balafon chromatique
je lui ai découvert par willy king qui a
crié le premier spécimen et moi je me
suis mis en tant que expérimentateurs et
c'est comme ça que en 2001 j'ai pu
mettre sur pied le balafon chromatique
de trois octaves de phase ii à face inc
qui est aujourd'hui reconnue par
l'organisation africaine de la propriété
intellectuelle je suis donc 2
panther versées alors ce balafon nous
permet de parler dialecte pour tout les
galettes de l'afrique mais nous permet
aussi de parler d'autres langues qui a
reconnu
merci et ça peut aller plus loin ça peut
aller plus loin ça peut parler des
langues comme celle ci
merci beaucoup
si alors que donc
excusez moi je suis un peu voilà le sort
d'une grippe donc alors c'est alors que
en 2001 je crée cet instrument qui est
reconnue seulement à partir de 2007
comme étant une invention par l'oapi ont
bien sûr fait qu'une pop et l actuel et
nous avons à partir de ce moment
beaucoup de choses qui se passent parce
que en 2002 je valide effectivement ma
recherche en formation continue à
l'université de strasbourg
ça s'appelle des diplômes de hautes
études des pratiques sociales et donc je
reviens au pays en côte d'ivoire parce
qu'à ce moment là la côte d'ivoire c'est
mon pays
oui le cameron devient le pays de
naissance la cotivo mon pays de coeur
pays où tout se passe et après c'est
donc le grand prix triangle du balafon
en 2005 que je gagne pour la côte
d'ivoire le camp pris à sikasso au mali
ça a été la reconnaissance de cet
instrument qui était considéré comme un
instrument occidental je dis non
soit parce qu'il a la gamme chromatique
maintenant c'est à dire les notes
blanches de notre noir d'un piano caché
une gamme occidental non c'est la gamme
universel dans le sens de conventionnel
tout simplement
et donc après le grand prix tirs de
balles à fond en 2005 on se retrouve aux
world masters of art and culture en
corée du sud en 2010 pour la côte
d'ivoire également
c'était une distinction merci
mais avant avant la corée du sud
mais c'est de la culture et de la
francophonie de côte d'ivoire en 2008 va
décerner une distinction c'était le
diplôme d'excellence pour le rayonnement
de leur événement culturel la côte
d'ivoire à l'extérieur des frontières en
2012 c'était le tour de l'unesco qui me
faisaient lorient pour mon projet à mort
ceux création d'une industrie culturelle
autour des balafons en côte d'ivoire et
ce projet qui nous a permis de faire de
la formation des formateurs
alors aujourd'hui nous avons aline sac
ainsi national des arts des dés de la
culture côte d'ivoire l'école nationale
de musique nous avons en pratique
instrumentale le balafon chromatique
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment un petit pas
même pas de chien oui alors nous avons
aujourd'hui donc le bancomat hic en tant
qu' une et essai des enseignants quand
ils formés par nos soins et nous avons
créé quelque chose que nous appelons le
big band balafon parce qu'aujourd'hui
dans le big band balafon nous avons des
hommes et des femmes
parité oblige dix hommes des femmes
parce qu'aujourd'hui les plafonds
concerne aussi les femmes et même des
enfants
plus besoin de faire un sacrifice
d'aller tuer pour l'aide à les tuer abri
non non non n'ayez plus peur de ça on
peut jouer ce qu'on veut là dessus
1 dès qu'on arrive un enfant il prend le
balafon tout de suite et c'est
vous reconnaissez aaa alors tout de
suite on peut le faire
en fait tout ce qu'on veut et dont il ya
donc des femmes et tout ça et nous avons
créé un festival un festival
international des balafons qui sera à sa
quatrième édition
en 2016 entre si je peux me permettre
entre le 30 novembre et le 10 décembre à
abidjan
il fait sur l'international des balafons
et un festival où nous déclinons tout un
balafon nous faisons intervenir le
meilleur groupe du monde on va faire
d'abidjan
le rendez vous mondial des îlots phone
et nos faisons venir des gens d'un peu
partout des grands artistes violoniste
et autres et nous déclinons leur
orchestration pas la faune en général et
donc c'est vraiment nous allons
communiquer vous serez certainement au
courant mais toujours est il que la la
plus value dans cette affaire surtout
dans le parcours de ces citadins là qui
a donc un certain moment s'est rendu
compte que en fait il n'était même pas
déraciner mais elle était suspendue
parce que lorsqu'on parle de
déracinement c'est ont pas d'une entité
qui est qui et qui est enraciné dans un
ancrage déjà avant mais lorsqu'on n'est
même pas à racine et on est tout
simplement suspendu
moi j'ai été un suspendu culturels comme
la plupart d'entre nous dans cette
afrique et même dans le monde parce que
le monde est de plus en plus on en a des
devils qui dans dix semaines dans les
villages aujourd'hui tout se passe comme
si on était en ville on a des enfants
dans leur berceau t qu'ils naissent ils
ont déjoué tout de suite et lorsque vous
actionnez le jouer c'est la musique
classique ils n'y peuvent rien mais au
fin fond des villages dans ça fait quand
ils grandissent ils grandissent avec des
influences du monde entier déjà à la
base
alors cela pour peu qu'ils ne
connaissent même pas comment ça se passe
dans leur village on ne pouvait pas leur
dit
qui sont afrique de du fin fond de
l'afrique c'est pas possible il faudrait
créer une nouvelle définition de soi et
donc comment alors comme on le dit comme
le dit le proverbe africain qui dit que
la raison de vivre d'un homme réside
dans sa culture
mais comment est-ce qu'on peut donc être
comme on peut donc vivre sans d'avoir
une culture net
alors où vient le moment non pas de
l'identification mais de
l'authentification
il faut bien que je m'identifie par
rapport à quelque chose par rapport à
une quête personnelle
né d'une prise de conscience et c'est
comme ça que l'africain se redéfinit pas
forcément s'ils ont lieu donné ou une
origine données mais si on le tout le
monde selon son vécu et selon
effectivement ce qu'il est et murray
apporter au monde entier alors je sais
pas ce qui va être content d'être là
présentez votre main si vous n'êtes pas
contents d'être là une main avec tout le
cndd doit déployer et alors je vous
invite à un exercice
essayez juste de plier le pousse alors
rempli le pousse alors faites comme si
vous n'aviez que quatre doigts et donc
que vous utilisez votre mère est qu'avec
les quatre doigts
c'est pas simple maintenant maintenant
bélier le pousse alors fait maintenant
comme si votre main parce qu'elle est
effectivement guéri si vous êtes soulagé
de quelque chose c'est mieux 20 avec
cinq doigts alors vous voyez le monde
fonctionne comme une main à quatre
doigts sans l'afrique comme une main à
quatre doigts sans l'afrique et comment
est ce que l'afrique peut rentrer dans
le monde sans intégrer les codes
comment est-ce que le traditionnel
joueur de balafon peu
communiquer avec le monde sans savoir
comment ça fonctionne dans la convention
musicale donc il ya un problème il ya un
problème de communication parce que
c'est un choix finalement de communiqué
il faut des bases
il faut des bases communes en avance
avec un pied comme tout le monde on
avance avec la norme comme tout le monde
il ya ensuite on propose d'autres choses
qui peuvent être profitables qui peuvent
être avantageuse aujourd'hui vaut la
faune chromatique et rentrer dans tous
le deux possibilités de la musique
nous avons des compositeurs aujourd'hui
qui travaille pour le balafon
chromatique tels que monsieur d'élèves
qui ferment cheptel qui faire et il est
à la retraite aujourd'hui grand
compositeur était directeur du
conservatoire de région de ce
conservateur du strasbourg d'un
compositeur balafon chromatique
alors nous avons monsieur pierre charvet
qui est en ce moment des retours des
programmes de france musique qui est un
très grand compositeur contemporain qui
composent pour la faune chromatique
on a de plus en plus de compositeurs qui
comme pas ou qui composent pour vous la
fantomatique de sorte que votre banque
au motif du bien à un instrument
universel comme tout ce que vous avez
comme le piano la guitare comme les
autres justement on peut plus dire
c'était seulement il est purement
africain d'origine bien sûr et vous
voyez là tu es dans la constitution et
voilà c'est vraiment fait la main de
façon artisanale
mais c'est un instrument devenu
universel tout le monde se l'approprier
et c'est en cela que je vous dirais
vraiment c'est pour nous une opportunité
pour l'afrique un non seulement
d'intégrer les codes universels dans le
sens de conventionnel mais aussi
maintenant de proposer en matière de
plus value de proposer comme dans le cas
d'espèce le teindre le timbre du balafon
dans toutes les musiques existe
au monde maintenant je n'entends plus la
musique comme avant j'entends la musique
avec pas la faune et parfois j'entends
l'absence du balafon parce que je sais
que maintenant c'est possible de le
faire et bien sûr si on me pose la
question de savoir si mon art me nourrit
alors je demanderai simplement personnes
de suivre mon regard merci laurent
gbagbo gagné un moteur pour la faune au
bâti